michel potage bonsoir a commencé au
théâtre non oui c'était quoi acteur
metteur en scène je faisais de la mise
en scène
et puis un jour tamil martelly je peux
plus non parce que j'arrive pas trop
travailler avec des gens way qui ne
savaient pas ce qu'ils voulaient ouais
elle essayait de travailler tout seul
oui alors j'ai donc fais de la peinture
ou malgré moi ça s'est passé comment la
première fois tu t'es retrouvé devant
devant une toile
ça fait quoi
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'horreur toujours c'est en ce
moment
je téléphone à quelqu'un
c'est qui c'est c'est arletty
et c'est quelqu'un qui pour moi a
représenté énormément de choses elle à
91 ans elle est aveugle
j'aimerais pouvoir lui faire un tableau
je lui donne ce tableau je crois que la
peinture c'est ces deux s'affrontaient
l'impossible c'est ça la peinture tout à
fait cette définition qui donnerait à
ces partis en australie pour peindre le
grand rêve aborigènes ça s'est passé
comment premium
j'ai eu interpol sur le dos ouais
parce que
les gens là bas il est vive à partir du
rêve sont en grève et cela n'est pas
correct
comment tu voulais pas voir le rêve oui
mais j'ai pas pu le peindre comme je
voulais peindre le cri ou vendredi le
vent c'est ça c'est parti pour panne le
rêve
oui j'ai pas un nom j'ai trouvé
j'ai trouvé quelque chose mais j'ai
surtout trouvé des gens après t'as
essayé de peindre à partir des lettres
de van gogh à son frère ça parle de quoi
leur voyage
tu serais qui comme panne s'il n'était
pas michel potash devrait être qui
personne
j'essaye d'être personnes
un homme maudit cette influence est
parti par bacon j'aime beaucoup
c'est se détruit de plus en plus au fur
et à mesure que je regarde du javelot et
au fur et à mesure que je peins vous
convient tableau de toi conte pardon
mais ça vaut un tableau de toi ça dépend
de la taille
un petit 10000 un grand 80 cents
t'écoutes quoi quand tu parles
iggy pop verchères la peur
peut-être ne sais pas c'est en tout cas
c'est quelqu'un qui m'apporte énormément
parce que s'il ya quelqu'un que j'aime
énormément si loulou l'horrible ça sert
à quoi la peinture à ton avis je crois
que si je fais de la peinture c'est
uniquement pour moi et pour quelques
amis et pas plus il n'y a pas d'autre si
on veut donner une définition de toi
dans le dictionnaire des pales tu
préférerais que ce soit quoi qu' aucun
dictionnaire les corrections de ne rien
rater de leonard itude abonnez vous
mettez un pouce bleus